georges kiejman au vide je bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir exceptionnel merci
à vous également merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation vous êtes président du
mouvement république souveraine je le
disais mais aussi spécialiste des
questions de défense vous avez notamment
conseillé jean luc mélenchon alors le
défilé du 14 juillet va débuter dans un
peu moins de deux heures maintenant avec
des conditions strictes puisque les
spectateurs devront être munis d'un pass
sanitaires mais aussi porter un masque
vous vous les comprenez ces restrictions
a priori non puisque le défilé se
passent en extérieur sur les
champs-elysées et on sait très bien que
le masque est assez inutile en extérieur
donc ça fait partie de la sorte de mini
dictature dictature sanitaire qu'impose
de présents dans la pub française
c'est le chemin qui a décidé nous nous y
opposons à laurière le chef de l'état
qui a annoncé la fin de l'opération
barkan dans la région du sahel au
premier trimestre 2001 22
est-ce que selon vous c'est le bon
moment où alors finalement est ce que ça
montre que cette opération elle a été un
échec
alors cette opération a été un grand
succès initial nos armées ont fait un
excellent travail en arrêtant les
colonnes djihadistes qui allait sur
bamako
malheureusement on a demandé à l'armée
française de faire un travail qui n'est
pas le sien qui est de gérer une
situation très complexe faite de
criminalité internationale de misère en
d league dans la région sahélienne de
développement du jihadisme de problèmes
terry dentiste de mauvaise gouvernance
de plusieurs états dont le mali ce que
bien évidemment l'armée n'est pas censé
faire et donc on s'est retrouvé dans une
situation qui est incomparable à celle
de l'afghanistan où dont les états unis
viennent de se retirer après vingt ans
de présence soit il le rappeler sans
aucun succès donc vu la situation vu le
développement des forces djihadistes au
sahel
vu que les problèmes structurels de la
région
ne sont pas réglés oui on peut
malheureusement considérer que c'est que
c'est un échec et que dans cette zone va
s'installer pour se développer des
forces djihadistes qui menaceront la
france dans les années à venir alors sur
l'action armée française le chef d'état
major des armées le général françois
lecointre c'est justement exprimé hier
sur l'opération barkan dans les colonnes
du monde notamment sur les conséquences
des frappes françaises regard des
démineurs ont pu être touchés parce
qu'ils n'avaient pas été identifiées
initialement comme tel j'ai en mémoire
un exemple particulier qui a fait
l'objet d'un compte rendu très précis à
la mine du sma et d'une communication à
la croix rouge
l'armée qui avait été mise en cause pour
la mort de civils après les frappes
votre réaction
malheureusement lors des conflits
ce sont des choses qui arrivent d'autant
que nous armer encore une fois comme en
afghanistan font face à des forces
djihadistes qui sont assimilés des
forces de guérilla qui se mêlent à la
population est bien évidemment
malheureusement ce genre d'accident
terrible arrive mis son éviction est à
déplorer
oui il faut bien évidemment toujours
toujours une enquête pour voir dans
quelle mesure sont arrivés ces tragiques
événements alors parmi les les défis a
évoqué par le chef d'état major des
armées il ya eu la question du spatial
comme nouveau milieu de confrontation
militaire
la cyber sécurité ou encore la lutte
contre les fausses informations
et justement hier le gouvernement a
annoncé la création d'une agence de
lutte contre les manipulations elle
s'appelle vigiles sommes regardés vie
jeune homme devra identifier des
opérations impliquant de manière directe
ou indirecte un état étranger ou une
entité non étatiques étrangères et
visant à la diffusion artificielle ou
automatisés massive et délibérée par le
biais d'un service de communication au
public en ligne d'allégations ou
d'imputation de fait manifestement
inexactes ou trompeuses de nature à
porter atteinte aux intérêts
fondamentaux de la nation
votre avis sur la création de cette
agence à quelques mois des élections
présidentielles est ce que c'est
indispensable pour la sécurité d'un pays
dans l'absolu bien évidemment en france
il faudrait développer cette cyber
défense cible de cyber espionnage le
cyber contre espionnage la cybersécurité
en général qui sont encore
malheureusement un parent pauvre de
notre défense donc c'était une bonne
chose que de développer maintenant c'est
étonnant de le faire de cette manière là
et on voit bien que dans la manière dont
c'est fait cela pour être
instrumentalisée par emmanuel macron
pour s'éviter des attaques et des
critiques politiques internes à la
france donc voyons à quoi va ressembler
cette agence mais bien évidemment que
nous avons des craintes quant à son
fonctionnement
alors le spatial la cybersécurité lézard
nouvelle génération bien tout cela ça
coûte cher
elle les parlementaires se sont
récemment inquiétés de l'avenir du
budget après 2022 eux mêmes mal macro on
le voyait là augmenté de 1,7 milliard
chaque année est-ce que c'est suffisant
selon vous il est suffisamment important
le budget des armées en france
aujourd'hui
écoutez le budget le problème du budget
n'est pas en soi c'est qu'est ce que
vous faites de l'armée que vous avez qui
compte quelle est la vision que nous
avons de la france dans le monde quelle
quelle place doit elle avoir et l'armée
doit être en appui à cette vision
géopolitique
or macro emmanuel macron à une vision
géopolitique atlantiste inféodés aux
états unis suiviste et il est pour un
transfert de souveraineté de la france
vers une souveraineté européenne qui
elle-même en terme de défense se
construit sous la halle de l'otan donc
sous les états unis ce qui fait que ce
budget qui tentent de promotion du pib
rappelez vous c'est une vieille demande
des états unis
trump le demander de manière assez
vindicative mais c'est une directive
littéralement venant de washington qui
n'a pas changé et le souci c'est que les
les demandes des militaires ne sont pas
temps suivi que cela car cette cette
mise sous tutelle des états unis et de
l'otan fait que nous achetons de
matériel qui n'est pas toujours adapté à
nos opérations du matériel autant du
matériel qui permet l'interopérabilité
avec l'armée américaine qui généralement
est lourd beaucoup plus cher qu'ils ont
beaucoup plus entretien et qui ne
correspond pas à ranger au cahier des
charges des militaires alors justement
le chef d'état-major des armées il s'est
exprimé hier sur cette question
notamment en ce qui concerne les
relations entre la chine et les états
unis qui ne cessent de se tendre le il a
plaidé pour que les français les
européens évite de s'engager dans cette
contrefaçon il faut un peu plus de
souveraineté est ce qu'il ya une
question entre finalement les chefs
militaires et le président de la
république sur cette question de la
souveraineté militaire
oui je vous le dis je pense qu'il ya
qu'il ya un problème c'est que soi que
nous sommes souverains soit ne le sommes
pas et tout est là or monsieur emmanuel
macron inscrire notre géopolitique et
donc notre défense
dans ce sillage dans le sillage
étasunien il est bien évidemment il est
bien évident que pour la france
bien que les activités en particulier
financière de la chine doivent être sous
une autre une certaine manière sous
notre contrôle mais nous n'avons aucun
intérêt à une situation de conflit avec
la chine
le redéploiement stratégique américain
en asie du sud-est ne devrait pas
particulièrement nous nous intéresser de
la même manière les tensions permanentes
avec la russie sont absurdes ne
correspond pas à nos intérêts
géopolitiques et demi et deux intérêts
économiques alors un nouveau chef d'état
major va prendre ses fonctions il sa
régie
général thierry burkhard lui c'est un
légionnaire d'ailleurs on entendait le
chef d'état major le général lecointe et
dire qu'il ne fallait pas faire croire
qu'il n'y avait pas finalement de
coïncidences politique
est-ce que néanmoins cette police est ce
choix et cette nomination elle est
politique selon vous d'abord je
souhaiterais noté le fait que comme
l'avait dit dans notre reportage ce
genre de démissions sont très rares mais
ce qui est aussi très rare c'est que
notre actuel présente dans la pluie aura
eu trois chefs d'état-major des armées
ce qui est un record absolu
et ce qui montre de facto une très forte
tension entre l'institution militaire et
le président de la république en
filigrane ça répond à certaines de vos
questions précédentes justement et
depuis la crise avec le général de
villiers tout au début de son
quinquennat
on voit bien que emmanuel macron
souhaite comme sur le reste de la
société sur le reste des institutions
avoir une contrôle total il ya une
manière monde et jupitérienne de
gouverner c'est à dire lui tout seul
dans son conseil de défense
ce qui est proprement ahurissant encore
une fois en dans une démocratie
véritable et donc oui c'est une
nomination
c'est une nomination politique monsieur
emmanuel macron met en place un maximum
d'éléments pour garantir sa réélection
en 2002 merci beaucoup georges kiejman
au vide spatial le permet allez moi je
vais vous présenter les choses
malheureusement comme vous l'avez quand
je les dis nous les etats unis quittent
l'afghanistan et beaucoup d'afghans
interprète ou qui ont aidé l'armée
française ont combattu avec nous sur le
terrain là-bas et malheureusement
beaucoup sont abandonnés et en ce 14
juillet c'est ce n'est pas un honneur
pour notre pays que d'abandonner ceux
qui ont versé les cendres qui aurait pu
verser le sang avec avec nos soldats et
voilages en juin
président de la république de faire ce
qui n'a pas été fait jusqu'à maintenant
c'est à dire de sauver ses interprètes
de les accueillir en france ainsi que
leurs familles merci georges kiejman
beach d'avoir été avec nous ce matin sur
rtl france je le rappelle vous êtes
président du mouvement république
souveraine